okay today I'm going to talk to you
about empirical formula and what
empirical formula basically means is the
simplest whole number ratio of atoms in
a compound now this might seem a little
bit confusing so I'm just going to
instantly show you an example because I
think that helps to visualize it so
let's say if we had c2h6 i've been asked
to find the empirical formula of this so
the simplest ratio of carbon to hydrogen
atoms now you might already be able to
see it but if you don't know how to do
this what you need to do is you divide
by the smaller number of the two so for
this one here I'm gonna do two divided
by two which equals one for my hydrogen
here I'm going to do six divided by two
which equals three so then I just need
to write this as a ratio my ratio is one
carbon atom to three hydrogen atoms so
how to write this out now is I've got
one carbon and three hydrogen's so that
there is my empirical formula the
simplest ratio of carbon to hydrogen now
we can either do this with more complex
molecules such as glucose c6h12o6 I've
got to find the empirical formula of
this right here so the first thing I do
again is I find the smallest number of
of all three of them which is six and
what I need to do is 6 divided by 6
equals 1 then for hydrogen what I need
to do is 12 divided by 6 which is 2 and
for oxygen over here it's 6 divided by 6
which is 1 so then I'm going to write
this as a ratio again don't worry you've
just got three numbers this time rather
than 2 so my ratio now is 1 to 2 so 1 so
how do I write that so one carbon so
just see two hydrogen's h2 one oxygen Oh
so my empirical formula my simpler
the whole number ratio of atoms within
here this is ch2o now that's how to find
the basic empirical formula but
sometimes we get exam questions that
look a bit like this a sample of calcium
bromide contains 0.2 grams of calcium
and 0.8 grams of bromine by mass
calculate the empirical formula of
calcium bromide so what we're trying to
do is we're trying to figure out calcium
bromide for example is it just capr is
it cabr - is it CA to be R we don't know
at the moment so we're trying to figure
out the ratio of calcium atoms to
bromine atoms so how do we go about this
the first thing that we need to do is
we're going to kind of do one at a time
we're going to start off with calcium so
remember because calcium and bromine
each atom has a different mass from each
other and the bromine is about twice the
mass one atom of bromine is twice the
mass of one atom of calcium we need to
factor this in so what you need to do is
you need to do the mass divided by the
atomic mass so 0.2 divided by forty for
calcium now that gives me 0.2 divided by
forty that gives me an answer of 0.005
okay next up what I need to do is I need
to do the same for bromine so I need to
take my mass 0.8 and divide it by my
relative atomic mass eighty so I use my
calculator again 0.8 divided by 80
equals 0.01 okay so now I need to think
of the ratio between calcium and bromine
so again you might be able to see this
straight away but the calculation you to
do remember is divided by the smaller
number
of the two which is this one here so the
calcium I'm going to do 0.005 divided by
zero point zero zero five which equals
one because I'm dividing the number by
itself this one I'm doing 0.01 divided
by the smaller number of the two which
is this one here 0.005 now if I'd use my
calculator 0.01 divided by 0.005
my answer is 2 so here I've got my ratio
one calcium so Toubro means so one to
two so then how do I finish this off by
writing my empirical formula so if we've
got one calcium I just write ca and if
I've got two bro means I did B r2 so
this here is the empirical formula of
calcium bromide so my steps first of all
divided by mass by my relative for
relative atomic mass if you don't if
they don't give you this remember you
can find these on the periodic table is
the bigger number on the atom then what
you need to do is once you've done that
for both of them you divide both of
these by the smaller number of the two
that should give you a ratio and then
you just need to write out the empirical
formula like that okay thank you very
much